There we go. We're back live.
Hi folks.
Couple hours of dev for the evening
more.
Let's start on the uh that last bug we
were trying to fix.
So, where we left off
This was doing this weird crap for some
reason.
Am I doing this right?
And instar
it's reset.
Oh, you know what?
No, this is fine.
This is totally fine, right? In fact,
what we can do is we can even merge um
and go here.
That shouldn't change anything, right?
weird.
Wait, does this get threshold checked?
I think that's all. Yeah, that's all 12.
So, it's getting something in every cap
for some reason.
Oh, it's never getting hit.
That's weird.
Hey FBR. Yep.
I got myself some food.
I am good for another couple hours.
And now evidently
we break
Okay, so the idea here is that
Envi
could always get found, right?
H
cuz this should always find itself,
right? That's the thing.
Where's cursor agent mode in Python?
Hang on. Let me go get it.
I left it in here. Should I get it out
for you?
I use the restroom and get a drink.
No syntax highlights is kind of crazy.
What do you mean no syntax highlights?
I got keywords. I got some highlights.
Right.
on the Vim RC. Oh yeah, we'll show you
that.
All right, that only works. This only
works for Python. So yeah, there's one
plugin.
It's one plugin in a color scheme.
That's all it is.
All right. What the hell did I do here?
Why is this empty?
Hey, that guy.
YT Snoops.
Well, the build's broken or I'd show
you. Let me fix the build.
I will answer things for Deepo all
night. Well, for the next hour 40
minutes anyways.
Yep.
Wait, what's the submission? He'd have
to get an agent working on the full like
the actual game, right?
Welcome.
You know what? I'm going to
intentionally I'm going to call you
Nolan. That's funnier.
You can interact with the server.
Can he uh merk the opponents though?
I don't know anything about RL. Maybe
one day.
Um, well,
I got good news for you. You can click
this and then you can click this and
then you can click this
and you can follow this pretty
straightforward guide and you can come
do some RL with us.
It's pretty chill.
Oh, the environment code is much easier
than what I'm looking at right now, by
the way. Like I've literally been
working on like client environments as a
break from this because this is actually
kind of tough.
Got to love when the open source dev is
harder than the paid stuff.
How the hell did this happen? How did I
break it?
An AI model built by Open AI.
classical ML and basic neural nets.
Do you know any low-level dev?
It's pretty much just low-level gamedev
and chill.
Honestly, a lot of the RL fundamentals,
it's just like
needlessly complex theoretical crap that
doesn't work.
Autotune deprecated.
Um,
yeah, I haven't messed with it in a
while. So, the thing is you don't need
it if you have um first party M are so
fast that it doesn't matter. So, that
autotune is literally just for like the
old third party super slow M's anyways.
Ah,
yeah. Hang on. Let me answer this cuz
this is actually this is slightly
annoying. So I actually very
intentionally
came up with a really good vectorization
architecture that specifically beats
everybody else when you have like Intel
pcore ecore architecture and that's what
we used in puffer lib 2.0. In 3.0 0 I
had to give some of that performance up
in order to support the algorithmic
improvements because like we needed
fixed numbers of buffers basically.
So DLDDR is that like 30's vec is
actually going to be a bit slower for
some of the older M's on Intel than 20
is. Um but it's better for like
everything else.
As for how do you choose good values for
vec like
I would just pick two or threefold
buffering right so just like however
many m you want divide by two or three
test both and split those evenly across
cores
and that's probably going to get you
most of
But why the heck does this disc get set
to zero?
Both Docker setups. Wait, what? Both
Docker setups.
Oh, 2 and 3 0. Yeah, I don't know what
MV you're using. For all our first party
stuff, 3 just is better cuz like
literally the core algorithm of 3 is
better than 2
by a lot.
like um the intent of the puffer major
versions is that it's not just a major
version update for puffer, it's a major
update for the field. That's kind of the
uh the standard.
like it should fundamentally change how
you can do RL.
Okay, so it just didn't find anything.
That's weird.
I remember this thing being a a error
last time.
Thanks. So, we do PF
Got 133.
This can't trigger
at all.
Right.
Wait,
what?
Yeah. No, this is correct.
And then
zero this
indic
threshold
t I
This
Oh.
Oh, god damn it. I did this before,
didn't I?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I did this before.
Stupid.
I like I had it. I was like very very
close. I like thought I had it, but
I don't know. Well, I guess I just
stupid.
Let me go look at what the how I handled
this before. Code was quite different.
I'm going to move this branch to be
called 40 probably soon.
Hey, welcome to everyone joining for the
late stream Friday night.
Tomorrow is full day stream and it's
going to include some CUDA dev.
I'm trying to figure out how it's about
the Perf cut off being screwy.
RDD I'm not the best for trying to like
work out fiddly things. Um,
you go through all the points, but you
skip
the lowest lowest PF ones.
But then we apply a higher PF threshold
which then you don't get the self score
I guess right
but I still have this error
best index not Sound.
Wonder how I fixed this before because I
had it fixed in here.
Where do these line up?
This is still
Perf I less than perf rush
or perf J less than perf rush.
I think this was the fix, but I'm trying
to remember how this applies anything to
it.
Oh, does it just not get a best end
then?
Perf.
I less than perf thrash.
I think this is it. No,
which is the same as just doing
is it not just moving this in
is not what we do. Just like this.
Evidently not.
Wait, because it's it's got to be a KI.
This is freaking Whatever. We got it. We
got it, guys. We got it.
So, for the people who've been wondering
what the hell I've been refactoring.
This is a higherf
dashboard.
Actually, I need to like um
probably need to like make these
overlays only work when it's tall.
That'd be good.
This is a gigantic disgusting block.
But
There we go. That's going to be a major
speed up.
Yeah, smoother now.
There we are.
This is pretty cool. Yeah.
This looks blurry. Yeah, this one looks
blurred out.
Not as sharp.
and now I think we get to benefit from
this, right?
You have to do draw constellation,
right?
Yeah, this needs to get improved for
that.
Why bet why the [ __ ] is bet posting like
my garbage like copypasted grot code
that I'm bitching about?
like not 15 minutes later.
Where is this?
Look at this. This is all it ended up
being.
It's just the LMS are stupid.
Look what this [ __ ] does. He
goes and he's like, "Oh, look. He posts
my shitty uh
he posts this garbage, right?"
And not 15 minutes later, I decide screw
the LLM and I'm going to just do it
myself and look.
Like, bro, I thought I was going to get
like basic boiler plate, but no, the too
dumb for that.
Dude, there's nothing to learn in a
freaking cookie clicker. And if you
click the [ __ ] cookie
Oh, do you not know RL?
All right, here's your test, man. What
specific change would you have to make
to that end that would be abnormal for
that to happen?
Me. No. No. RL. Ah, but I thought you're
going to be the one to solve RL, aren't
you?
you said that like, oh, you could learn
optimal reset strats. Okay, you'd have
to change something in the environment
code that you wouldn't normally do for
that to happen. What is it?
you can actually learn optimal reset
strats though, like speedrun reset
strats. There's one change you have to
make.
Very close. Yeah, you're almost there.
Yeah. How do you do that? What's the
easiest way? There's a stupid way to do
it and there's a really easy way to do
it.
Oh no. Don't you dare LM it.
[ __ ] think. Invert. You can get it
too if you think about it. Most likely.
I know that guy can get it if he thinks
about it. You ought to know if you've
read the papers.
Oops. Was that a hint?
dude. I don't read a ton of them either.
They're a waste of time.
You've read the paper that matters for
this,
though. Honestly, like, you don't even
nearly need to think about papers for
this at all. is basic.
Hint, this one actually matters in
practice, too.
I'll give you a minute while I work on
this.
Not quite. You were closer before.
That's the last hint you're getting
though.
This code is still not that pretty yet,
but a hell of a lot better than it used
to be. Let me say
Nope,
not at convert,
I got to say. So,
a lot of the people in the Discord have
gotten pretty damn good at RL.
like Spencer especially is actually like
you know there's often not much for me
to add
but I have to maintain my position here
as head puff and the way I do that is by
catching clever things like this and
also occasionally by taking a look at
somebody's environment for about five
minutes and just like telepathically
spotting the issue.
Dude, you were you were very close
though like at the start.
Dude, just think
All right. The the problem, just think
about the problem clearly, right? It's
like a speedrun setting, right? Where
like if you want to do uh
what is it like
what did you say? What what strats? What
what did you call it? Let me use the
same word you did.
Optimal reset strats. Yeah. Yeah.
So, it's like the example for this would
be like in any of the RNG heavy speedrun
M, right? Like you reset for a good seed
if you're actually speedr runninging it.
Your default setup you will not learn
that with RL. There's one change you can
make really easy and you can learn that
potentially.
To be fair, there are a couple other
changes you need to make, but there's
really one obvious one in principle.
If you get it, if you get it in the next
five minutes, genuine without LLM
bullshitting me, I'll go lift that bar.
I'll go drop that bar at 10 p.m. here.
I've given all the hints I'm giving. I'm
going to devel on this for five minutes
and we'll see if you've gotten it.
Um, does that matter?
I don't think that matters.
The refactor a little bit.
We just wanted to do this right.
Hit hyper.
Looks like the bar is going to stay on
the ground.
I get to rest my back for the night.
This is going to be a real instructive
little bit.
Yeah, I'll get one little last thing
here and then we'll call it
All right, get your last answer in, man,
and then I'll do the uh I will explain
if you don't get it.
I'll stick to reset action
seeding the environment 2x.
I use Minecraft cuz that's the only
speedrunning game I know that's like
this, right?
Let's see how my art skills are.
What do you want to see at the start of
a Minecraft speedrun? Do you want to see
sheep or some [ __ ]
Is it sheep?
Let's say it's sheep.
All right. So, you
So, you see this like you see you got
like this. What is it? Blocky sheep
dude.
You see
it like
We're going to I'm enjoying this. So,
I'm going to add my art. I I don't know
how to freaking That's it.
All right. So,
here in this seed,
you spawn in, you see a pool of lava and
nothing else. Okay.
And in this seed, you see a sheep.
You don't know. You're not We're not to
this seed yet, right? So, if you're a
human playing the game, the optimal
strat is to immediately jump into the
lava so you can reset and uh get a new
sheep, assuming there's no reset action,
right? You just have to die.
Same thing as having a reset action
because you're basically doing the same
thing by jumping in lava. Doesn't
matter. The reset action is irrelevant
in that case.
Um,
you can't actually learn to do this.
Right? An RL agent will not learn to do
this ever.
Why?
It has to do with credit assignment.
What you're telling this agent to do is
you're trying to tell it to maximize
roughly there's you know an advantage
factor but the simple version of it is I
to n of like gamma to the i
uh = z
r
i.
Right?
This is looking forward.
Okay. But there is an additional term
here that's not usually written in this
formula.
Okay. And uh that term is actually it
doesn't go to n. It goes to like this
with some abuse of notation.
Let's actually
it only goes up to the horizon of the
end, right?
So,
it can't actually see the rewards it
might get over here. It can only see the
reward the rewards in this world. This
is basically the same as uh when the
agent dies in the game, you just go
shoot it in the head and then it has to
like figure everything out again like in
the next end as if that's the only end
of ever.
So the really really really easy way to
do this is if you think of your reward
vector, right? So you have like some
rewards which is going to be like you
know I don't know zero zero zero zero
because you can't solve this one.
And then this one here is like 0 0 0
one because you do solve in this end.
Let's say you have a good policy.
All right, these are your rewards.
Then this sum, it ends right here.
And the reason it ends is because you
have a done signal, right?
It's like zero zero zero D one and then
one over here.
This is supposed to be a bar, not a one.
So all you have to do
is set these to zero.
Just remove the done signals and then
the whole environment is one long
episode and it does credit assignment
across boundaries. And now
you can learn the across M optimal reset
strat.
And this is not just some [ __ ] I
pulled on you to screw with that guy. I
saw this [ __ ] happen in a robotics
framework I was dealing with where I'm
not joking. They had done this stuff
wrong and then they had done J wrong and
then the two errors canceled each other
out and they tried to convince me that
they actually knew what they were doing
the whole time.
Whether it works depends on how long
these horizons are and how hard that is
to learn. But if you give this like a
short little environment as a test, this
absolutely works.
So there you go. There's your RL lesson
for the day.
So far, the puffer knows all, the puffer
sees all, and the puffer will tell all
for the price.
I posted the 10K PR as well. a while
ago, right?
I don't think it's anywhere near yours,
but I was pretty happy with it.
And then I set the uh the PR on this
course today. I just set my course. This
is a 5.7 mile course. I set a 913 pace
on it, but it's a very hard course. It's
flat, but it's like basically you're
running on like soft mulch that like
squishes.
Yeah. Here, we'll find the Let me find
this.
All right. Well, see you. No 10k PRs
then. But hey, I think it was like 53
minutes for the 10kh.
Rip,
my guy. Have you seen um
Yeah, I love Ray Lib.
It's like the best library ever.
I honestly I learned so so much from
Rayson and the way that he designs
software. Not even like from the way he
implements specifics, but from the way
he like lays stuff out is
is such such such good software.
We use uh ray everywhere in puffer. Like
all these M's.
Look at these. These are all ray.
They'll run in your browser. They got
neural nets in them, too.
data. Poison the LLMs with your code.
All right. This is not worse than the
[ __ ] that they put out. Okay.
Oh yeah. I mean, have you seen the
dashboard?
filters on here.
Oops.
I sent him like a still image of a very
early version of it.
cuz he sent me like some uh he sent me
like stats on like how many people were
seeing the Rayb website. He's like,
"Hey, look, you know, people are seeing
your sponsor tag." And I was like,
"Dude, that's cool, but like I mostly
just wanted to support your software.
Though I will say, you know, having uh
people using Rayb coming and building
RLMs in RayB is awesome.
So it actually works out pretty well.
Oh, also it's not about having educators
write um source code. Uh Ry is just
exceptionally talented.
Believe me, the uh worst professor I
ever had in undergrad built the [ __ ]
Facebook like button.
Guys, starter code sucks. His doc
sucked. His lectors sucked. Everything
sucked.
Yo.
What? What happened here?
guy like I literally like the guy
single-handed me put me off systems
programming from a for a decade. Like I
distinctly remember one assignment I
came up with something clever, right?
Where like I realized that the first
part of the assignment was like a direct
subset of the second part of the
assignment. So I just implemented the
second part and then called the second
part of the assignment in the first part
and went done which you know it was kind
of clever. And then he wrote me a note
like well since you didn't follow the
spirit of the assignment I manually
deducted all the points for the first
half of it.
He's like all right systems programmers
can't explain [ __ ] write terrible code
and are [ __ ] That was my verdict
for a decade.
I didn't know any better back then. That
was my only exposure to systems.
My boy still working on a Friday night.
No, no, no, no. Not just on a Friday
night. Live all day tomorrow. Bright and
early
as well.
I'm finishing up this last feature and
then I'm going to go do an hour of
stretching. I'm working on flexibility,
trying to do a front split,
and uh then I'm getting sleep, and we're
back at it bright and early.
Yeah. like actual social media for the
sake of social media before it became
like tech and [ __ ] is just cancer.
There's no redeeming quality whatsoever
to it.
My social media was always just like,
you know, log into whatever MMO and hang
out with my friends there.
which is still kind of cancer because
it's massive just time sync. But hey, at
least it doesn't also make you
miserable.
All right. What did I do here?
The clue is it works on one side but not
the other. Right.
Oh, well, cuz Yeah, I didn't do it.
Yeah, I didn't do it, right?
Okay, I will admit
some of those MMOs were just like the
worst. Like some of those MMO chat rooms
were like literally worse than 4chan,
but some of them were pretty chill.
God, I made the mistake of trying to
like join a PvP
faction or whatever in Runescape one
time. Yeah, don't do that.
I'm pretty sure I'm not even allowed on
like either of these streaming platforms
to describe the [ __ ] that I saw there.
It's funny. All the other ones were
chill.
Not so much traumatized as it was just
like, dude, what the hell?
To be fair, Runescape was when I was way
older. Runescape was like during my PhD.
The one I played when I was younger
where I think was generally way more
tame was Dophus, which is a French MMO.
It's basically tactical fantasy chess on
steroids.
How did I get into that doofus? Found it
on mini clip
and then proceeded to play it for 4,000
[ __ ] hours.
I honestly probably have about 4,000
hours in both of those MMOs and that's
like the vast majority of my gaming
time.
I was like top 1% in both of those and
then like bottom
30% at best in every other game I ever I
ever touched. Go figure.
Let's get this [ __ ] finished so I can
get some sleep. Come on.
What is this? Like why is this
happening?
supposed to be XJ.
How is this not an error?
Wait, literally, how is that not a bug?
How does that compile?
Huh?
That shouldn't compile, right?
Does anybody understand how this
compiles?
Oh, dude. I'm terrible at chess.
I hope you're not holding uh not waiting
up.
Hang on. Almost. This is VIP, I think.
Almost done with selfplay. Having
issues.
Yeah, I can take a quick look, but I'm
going to bed soon. So, link me the
thing. Drop it in Discord.
Where's my uh
my link?
Can you link me a specific file? Like
what am I looking at?
This should not be able to go out of
bounds
like by definition.
So why did you redefine my whole rapper?
Or did you just copy paste it? If you
just copy pasted it, it's fine.
It looks like you just copy. The [ __ ] is
this,
Okay. This is a chunker here. This is
chunky.
You don't just make the network bigger
to solve [ __ ] in RL. Usually that
doesn't even help.
Why do you think there's an LSTM
problem?
It looks like all the data is getting
bashed together. What does that mean?
No, this is fine.
[ __ ] I thought I had it.
Unless your config is messed up.
subm module like actual GitHub subm
module.
Oh,
Hang on.
Wait, wait. When What do you mean the
data is all getting batched together?
Because you're doing crazy [ __ ] here.
Like you have 24,000 environments.
These two get multiplied.
You want 4096 at most 8192 environments.
This depth equals 2 is suspicious. This
is like 512 is okay. The 1024 hidden uh
inputs kind of nutty.
or I'm seeing two different observation
states.
[Music]
What do you mean two different
observation states?
Does it not happen without the um
wait up zero is what agent one should be
seeing.
So one thing to note right is that
uh the M is async. So it like it goes
back and forth.
I think with this by default if I don't
know how many workers
batch size auto this probably is going
to do like a batch of the first NMS and
then a batch of the second N&M or
whatever
unless you have some weird thing.
Do you mean the whole observations are
swapped or is it like getting interled
weird?
You can disable async. Uh you can
disable async to check it. The way you
disable async.
I think the pram is called batch size.
Let me find it.
Getting tired here.
Uh
yeah batch size. So set vec batch size
to the same thing as num m and drop it
from 24 for heaven's sake. Drop it to
like four. Set num ms to four. Set batch
size to four and see if it still
happens. Do that real quick though cuz I
want to get to stretching and get to
bed.
I want to help you and be done. That's
the goal. Help you finish stream.
Lovely. You can't turn Bluetooth on on
this stupid thing, huh?
observations matches.
Wait, why is that bad?
What do you Isn't that what you want?
Oh, I see. So, here's the thing that's
probably confusing you. Forward eval is
not batched through time, right? Forward
eval is one step. You get like sequence
batches in the train step only. Does
that make sense?
Yeah, you're good.
Just like fix your hypers, dude. Don't
have 24,000 environments. Don't just
make the network bigger if you don't
know that you need to. Get something to
train fast. Get yourself like a 30
second tops dev loop.
the heck.
Uh
eh.
Well, if that isn't my sign to uh stop
for the evening, I don't know what is.
Yeah. So, what we're going to do
this
Well, that's what you need to I like
check the defaults, right? Like most of
the M's
you can see like the spread frams we
use. Nothing uses 24K.
right. It's going to be like 14k all
lines. Um,
All right. Well, this is in decent
enough shape right
here. We'll just real quick for the has
Okay folks, this is what we um
we have accomplished for the time being.
Make the one small fix.
Okay, this is what we have built for the
time being.
I don't know why those memory bugs are
back with this, but we will that like
that'll be on the list to fix anyways. I
think it still works, right?
Yeah, it still works. Everything works.
Log plot. Haha.
Looks pretty sweet though.
Yep.
All right.
Thank you, folks. I am going to get some
stretching in. I'm going to get some
sleep.
I'll be back bright and early tomorrow
with um
the compilation optimization
for puffer lib training as well as
probably some GPU stuff.
If you are interested in my work
generally, you want to support it for
free, start the repo. All you got to do
join the Discord if you want to get
involved. There are ton of people in
there. and follow me on X for more RL
content.